die stimmung hier im gericht ist sehr
gedrückt bei den justizwachtmeistern bei
den anderen angestellten bei besuchern
hier im gericht wegen der korona
vorschriften sind die besucher zwar
nicht so viele aber alle fragen hier an
dem saal hinter mir vor dem ich stehe wo
gleich der prozess stattfindet findet da
heute dieser prozess statt das thema
hier in der stadt
es herrscht wie gesagt große
betroffenheit bei allen menschen auch
als die justiz bullys die gefangenen
brachten die heute auf der anklagebank
sitzen werden sollten sie sich draußen
menschen liefen teilweise auch etwas den
menschen zu was ich hier nicht
wiederholen möchte ein mann sagt eben zu
mir serie am besten man sperrt sie
wirklich für immer weg dass sich anderen
kindern dieses nicht mehr antun können
wir durften vorhin vorab mal in den
gerichtssaal und durften sie uns in
angucken
denn das problem ist der gerichtssaal
ist eigentlich relativ groß ist ist der
größte hier aber aufgrund der korona
vorschriften hat sich dort im saal
einiges geändert wir haben eine kleine
max gedreht die kollegen können die
bitte mal einspielen
wir durften jetzt vorab vor der prozess
heute mittag beginnt schon einmal in
diesen raum und können einmal zeigen das
war gerade der platz der
staatsanwaltschaft auch dort sind
trennwände angebracht wegen corona
dort werden hinterher die staatsanwälte
platz nehmen kroner ist ein großes thema
hier in diesem saal man wird es auch
hier sehen auf diesen tischen sind
plexiglas trennscheibe angebracht hier
werden intern die nebenkläger die
sachverständige und gutachter sitzen
das ist normalerweise bereich in dem das
publikum sitzt dort sind jetzt verstreut
diese tische wo eben nebenklage mit
ihren anwälten sitzt und eben auch das
jugendamt und sachverständigen gutachten
in diesem verfahren hier vorne sehen wir
die richter tische hier werden wird die
kammer sitzen
auch dort sind plexiglasscheiben
angebracht worden hier vorerst noch mal
einen extra absperrungen auch eben den
abstand zu wahren weil ja die richter
natürlich nach vorne sprechen damit die
ein meter fünfzig eingehalten werden und
hier hinten sieht man noch mal das sind
die anklage bänke hier werden intern die
vier männer und die frau platz nehmen
die angeklagt sind den sie ins verfahren
dort werden die kinderschänder sitzen
und hier hinten gleich noch einmal zu
zeigen vor kopf sind wenige presse und
zuschauerplätze wie gesagt normalerweise
sind hier in dem raum ganz viele
zuschauer möglich ist der größte saal
den das landgericht hier hat aber
aufgrund von kona war es nicht anders
möglich ist gab vor auch eine absprache
mit gesundheitsamt und ordnungsamt und
dort wurde besprochen da
eben nur so viele menschen in den raum
dürfen um die krone regeln einzuhalten
und das ist natürlich für dieses gericht
ein problem gewesen
anders war es aber leider nicht möglich
als jetzt so wie es momentan aussieht ja
frank das ist wirklich ein fall der ganz
deutschland schockiert hat was macht ihn
so besonders grausam und perfide
ja man muss sagen was ihn so besonders
grausamen perfide macht das ist ja in
einer kette von fällen der dritte war
wir hatten erst flüchtete dann hatten
wir bergisch gladbach und dann kam
dieser fall in münster mit datenmengen
wir haben es eben vom staatsanwalt
gehört auf festplatten gespeichert an
die 1000 terabyte sind ist mittlerweile
wo grausamste misshandlungs und
missbrauchsfälle wurden
und das hat auch das
vorstellungsvermögen viele ermittler
gesprengt man kann diese details was
dort zu sehen ist wirklich hier nicht
nennen es ist ganz schrecklich was in
der anklage steht zu ihm gehen wir auch
davon aus dass die anklage hier nachher
unter ausschluss der öffentlichkeit
verlesen wird um eben die opfer zu
schützen damit nicht öffentlich gemacht
wird was für schreckliche dinge ihnen
angetan wurden was ist so besonders
perfide noch dazu macht ist dass die
mutter des haupttäters mit auf der
anklagebank sitzt das heißt mehr oder
weniger die stief oma eines opfers sie
hat damals bei diesen schrecklichen
missbrauch in der laube dort haben vier
männer zum geburtstag des haupttäters
zwei jungen über zig stunden missbraucht
auf schrecklichste art und weise hat sie
ihn noch viel spaß gewünscht ist am
nächsten morgen die laube gekommen die
ihr auch gehört sie hat sie praktisch
für die taten zur verfügung gestellt ist
am nächsten morgen die laube und hat den
den kinderschändern frühstück gemacht
nach dieser missbrauchs nacht und sie
wusste genau es wurde darüber gesprochen
während sie mit im raum war was in der
nacht passiert war
sie hat die kinder nicht geschützt sie
hat das ganze unterstützt und sie wird
mit auf der anklagebank sitzen dazu
kommt noch dass der täter vorbestraft
war und zwar zweimal der haupttäter zwei
mal zwei jahre auf bewährung bekommen
trotzdem sei das jugendamt keine gefahr
als er damit einer alleinerziehenden
mutter zusammen kam angeblich zu würde
er reue zeigen hier habe eine therapie
gemacht es ging keine gefahr von ihm aus
und das war wirklich ein fataler irrtum
man hat gesehen er ist mit dem jungen
quer durch deutschland gefahren mit
einem bulli er hat den jungen männern
regelrecht angeboten hat ihn dann ins
auto gepackt ist durch deutschland
gefahren und das muss man auch mal sagen
das thema corona habe ich eben schon
angesprochen und das ist da auch noch
mal ein thema
man muss sich vorstellen die junge hatte
frey im lockdown im frühjahr und dann
hat der stiefvater nichts besseres zu
tun als ihn ins auto zu packen und mit
ihnen tausende von kilometern quer durch
die republik zu fahren und den überall
anderen kinderschändern anzubieten und
das ist wie gesagt eine ein grausames
ausmaß eine dimension von sexualisierter
gewalt gegen kinder
das hat man so bislang noch nicht
gekannt aber man muss sagen es ist eine
reihe von fällen mittlerweile und es ist
ein problem dass es mitten in der
gesellschaft und da muss unbedingt mehr
gegen getan werden mehr nachrichten und
breaking news nur bei bate schaut euch
hier das nächste video an und vergiss
nicht zu abonnieren